THE
MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
ON JULY 20, CONGRESS WILL RETURN
TO WASHINGTON WITH JUST ONE
OBJECTIVE, HAMMERING OUT THE
NEXT STIMULUS BILL.
THE BIPARTISAN TALKS HAPPENING
JUST AS THE EXTRA $600 IN WEEKLY
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS IS SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE CHAIRMAN,
SENATOR JOHN BARRASSO AND
SENATOR IT’S ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO SEE YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
TELL ME WHAT YOUR PLANS ARE IN
TERMS OF THE CARES ACT OR  THE
NEXT PART OF THE CARES ACT,
ANOTHER STIMULUS PLAN.
>> YEAH, THERE’S A CON SENSE
YOU WE NEED TO DO ANOTHER BILL
THAT’LL BE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS AND LET ME JUST TELL YOU
WHAT I BELIEVE NEEDS TO BE IN IT
AND I THINK YOUR VIEWERS WILL
AGREE.
NUMBER ONE, IT HAS TO FOCUS ON
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK, AND
CHILDREN BACK IN SCHOOL.
NUMBER TWO, IT HAS TO FOCUS ON
SAVING LIVES AND TO ME THAT
MEANS MORE TESTING, BETTER
TREATMENT, AND THEN OF COURSE, A
VACCINE, AND FINALLY, WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THE LIABILITY INSURANCE
FOR OUR HEALTHCARE WORKERS, FOR
OUR MOM AND POP SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND FOR OUR SCHOOLS
SO THEY CAN ALL OPEN IN A GOOD
WAY.
NOW, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
PROPOSAL ALREADY.
THEY PASSED IT A MONTH OR  SO
AGO AND IT’S NANCY PELOSI LIVING
IN HANDOUT HEAVEN.
IT’S DIRECT CHECKS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
IT’S BAILOUTS TO BIG CITY AND
STATE PENSION PLANS THAT ARE RUN
BY DEMOCRATS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL HAS TO BE
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK, AND
PAYCHECKS BACK INTO THEIR
POCKETS.
MARIA: SO YOU’RE BACK ON JULY 20
, BUT THEN THERE’S
ANOTHER RECESS BEGINNING ON
AUGUST 8, RIGHT?
DO YOU THINK IN THAT THREE-WEEK
PERIOD YOU’RE GOING TO GET
ANOTHER STIMULUS PLAN PASSED
AND SIGNED BEFORE YOU LEAVE
AGAIN AUGUST 8?
>> WELL THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
DEADLINES AS YOU MENTIONED ONE
IS THE ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS THAT RUN OUT
ON JULY 31.
THE OTHER IS THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM WHICH HAS
BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL.
THAT RUNS OUT ON AUGUST 8.
THAT’S HELPED KEEP ABOUT
50 MILLION PEOPLE ON A PAYROLL
AND IN WYOMING WE HAD 13,000 OF
THOSE LOANS, SO YEAH, THERE’S AN
YOU’RE AGAINST IT URGENCY TO
GET THIS DONE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS IN THE COMPONENTS OF IT
BUT THE QUESTION IS SHOULD IT
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL RELIEF CHECKS
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE STILL NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET BACK TO WORK
CERTAINLY IN HARD HIT INDUSTRIES
WHETHER IT’S THE SERVICE
INDUSTRY, THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY, YOU KNOW, WE DID THAT
ONCE BEFORE, BUT THAT WAS PEOPLE
UP TO $95,000, WE’RE LOOKING AT
A LOWER NUMBER THERE, AND THEN
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AS
YOU RAISED THESE ARE ENHANCED
BENEFITS WHERE THEY’VE BEEN
PAYING PEOPLE $600 A WEEK ABOVE
THEIR OWN STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
MARIA: RIGHT AND SOME OF THEM
ARE MAKING MORE TO STAY HOME
RATHER THAN TO GO TO WORK.
STAY WITH US SENATOR I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT MASKS AND WHETHER
IT SHOULD BE A POLICY IN THAT
MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
WE ARE BACK WITH SENATOR JOHN
BARRASSO, AND SENATOR I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT MASKS AND WHETHER
OR  NOT THAT SHOULD BE PART OF
YOUR CARES ACT.
THERE ARE SOME STATES THAT MADE
WEARING A MASK A POLICY.
SHOULD IT BE A NATIONAL POLICY?
>> WELL LET ME JUST SAY MARIA
AS A DOCTOR I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
WEARING HIS MASK YESTERDAY
IN PUBLIC FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
I THINK THAT SENDS A VERY STRONG
MESSAGE TO EVERYONE.
WE KNOW THAT MASKS LOWER THE
RISK OF INFECTION.
WE KNOW IT LOWERS THE RISK OF
DEATH AND IN THIS RECENT UP-TICK
, I JUST THINK IT’S EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER, AND
YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO
OPENING SCHOOLS THESE ARE GOING
TO BE LOCAL DECISIONS, MADE
DECISIONS BUT I JUST THINK IN
TERMS OF GOOD PLANNING, AND GOOD
HEALTH AS PEOPLE TRY TO RESUME
THEIR NORMAL LIVES, MASKS,
PERSONAL HYGIENE, WASHING THEIR
HANDS, SOCIALLY DISTANCING
THAT’S ALL PART OF THIS AS WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT THIS DISEASE.
MARIA: ALL RIGHT, AND REAL QUICK
, ON THE NEXT CARES ACT,
WHEN YOU GET BACK ON THE 20TH,
IT DOESN’T SOUND LIKE YOU’RE
GOING TO LEAVE ON AUGUST 8
WITHOUT ANYTHING GETTING DONE.
SHOULD I ASSUME WE WILL HAVE
ANOTHER STIMULUS PACKAGE IN THAT
THREE WEEK PERIOD?
>> THERE IS GENERAL AGREEMENT
WE NEED TO WORK TO THAT END AND
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES
AFFECTING OUR NATION.
THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE WHO CAN’T
GO BACK TO WORK THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN BECAUSE OF THE
DISEASE, BECAUSE OF MAYBE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE CARED FOR BUT WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO PAY PEOPLE MORE TO
SIT AT HOME THAN TO GO TO WORK
AND WE HAVE SO MANY HELP WANTED
SIGNS AROUND WYOMING AND THE
COUNTRY WE NEED TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
AND HELP THEM EARN THAT PAYCHECK
MARIA: SENATOR REAL QUICK BEFORE
WE GO THE SENATE UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED THAT BIPARTISAN BILL TO
SANCTION CHINESE OFFICIALS WHO
THREATEN HONG KONG’S AUTHORITY
BUT THE PRESIDENT HASN’T SIGNED
IT YET, RIGHT?
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THIS SEND TO
THE COMMUNIST PARTY AND WILL WE
SEE THIS GET SIGNED INTO LAW, DO
YOU THINK?
WELL THE COMMUNIST CHINESE ARE
NOT OUR FRIENDS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
MY MESSAGE TO THE CHINESE IS
NEVER AGAIN, NEVER AGAIN WILL WE
AS AMERICANS BE DEPENDENT UPON
YOU THE COMMUNIST CHINESE FOR
MEDICINES FOR MATERIALS, FOR
MINERALS.
WHAT YOU’RE SEEING HERE WITH
WHAT THEY’RE DOING, MARIA WITH
THIS GROUP WITH HONG KONG WITH
THE CHINESE INTO THE SOUTH CHINA
SEA IT’S ALL PART OF THEIR BIG
PLAN TO BE THE MILITARY, THE
ECONOMIC END AND THE